mais soirée bienvenue ça vous regarde en
direct je suis ravi de vous retrouver au
sommaire ce soir duel de programmes sur
le pouvoir d'achat la veille du débat
décisif d'entre deux tours on va passer
au crible les propositions des manuels
macro et de marine le pen sur la grande
priorité des français dans cette
campagne prix de l'énergie de
l'alimentation pensions de retraites
salaires qui propose quoi qui est le
plus crédible face à face à suivre sur
ce plateau arbitré par deux experts dans
un instant notre grand témoin ce soir
nous permet d'évoquer la présidentielle
d'une autre manière il est arrivé en
france en tant que réfugiés politiques
syriens il y a dix ans au terme d'un
long parcours semé d'embûches il a voté
pour la première fois dans notre pays le
10 avril dernier il raconte dans son
dernier roman une chambre en exil son
étonnement face à la fatigue
démocratique d'un pays
désenchanté omar youssef souleymane est
avec nous ce soir enfin dans le scan ce
soir jean rémi baudot nous dira pourquoi
ce deuxième tour se joue non pas à deux
mais à 3 démissionner tout de suite ou
plus tard géraldine muhlmann ausculte
les scénarii qui s'offrent aux premiers
ministres jean castex après l'élection
et puis l'oeil de blacko bien sûr le
carnet de campagne quotidien signé
stéphane blakowski voilà pour le menu
c'est parti
[Musique]
et bienvenue à vous chers
téléspectateurs s'il ya un thème auquel
vous allez c'est sûr être très attentifs
demain soir lors du débat d'entre deux
tours c'est celui du pouvoir d'achat
d'ailleurs ce sera le premier thème
abordé voilà pourquoi nous vous
proposons ce soir de vous donner toutes
les clés pour le comprendre bonsoir leur
enfin martin bonjour et merci d'être là
députée la république en marche sortant
du val de marne vous débattez ce soir
avec laure la valette soirée bienvenue
porte parole du rassemblement national
conseillère régionale est reine en paca
et puis dans la position d'arbitré un
journaliste ce soir dominique ceaux
bonjour ravi de vous retrouver sur ce
plateau délégué directeur délégué de la
rédaction des échos et éditorialiste à
france inter éditorialiste économique
est un économiste qu'on soit mathieu
plane vous êtes économiste à la fc alors
on va commencer par le programme de
marine le pen avec cette mesure phare la
baisse de la tva sur l'énergie gaz
électricité et carburant et puis sur
l'alimentation également tour de raisons
signé nicolas qu elle où elle aime se
présenter comme la candidate du pouvoir
d'achat
nous met dans le programme de marine le
pen pas d'augmentation du salaire
minimum
la candidate préfèrent se tourner vers
le patronat carotte fiscale à la clé ce
sera aux entreprises d'augmenter de 10%
les salaires jusque trois fois le smic
en échange d'une exonération des charges
patronales
une mesure au bon vouloir des battront
qui devrait créer un manque à gagner
pour l'état et qu'il faudra bien
compenser quelque part face à une
inflation galopante 4 5 points en mars
la candidate propose de baisser la tva
de 20 à 5 5% sur l'énergie dont les
carburants pourquoi parce que ce sont
des produits de première nécessité et ça
fait tout de suite baissé le plein de
gazole de 48 2 8 euros permettez moi de
vous dire que les français vont
immédiatement pouvoir respirer et voir
évidemment leur pouvoir d'achat
augmenter elle veut même la supprimer
sur une centaine de produits de première
nécessité comme le pain ou encore les
pattes encore une fois une mesure qui
risque de coûter très cher la tva
représente près de 40% des recettes
fiscales de l'état pour les retraités
marine le pen entend porter le minimum
vieillesse à 1000 euros il avait été
revalorisée par emmanuel macron hauteur
de 916 euros sur le quinquennat elle
compte aussi indexé les retraites sur
l'inflation une mesure théoriquement
présente dans la loi mais inappliqué
enfin comme son adversaire marine le pen
souhaite supprimer la redevance 238
euros par foyer en privatisant une
grande partie de l'audiovisuel public
alors on va commencer tout de suite par
la baisse de la tva énergie et
alimentation il ya beaucoup
d'interrogations la valette on entend
déjà le coût de la mesure rien que 12
milliards sur sur l'essence et puis
mesures non ciblés qui profite à tous
donc aux plus riches et pas forcément à
ceux qui en ont le plus besoin qu'est ce
que vous répondez à ceux là qui profite
à tous parce qu'à la fin de ce
quinquennat macro tout le monde a perdu
en pouvoir d'achat je dirais vous a pas
échappé que les français ont du mal à
remplir leur frigidaire ont du mal à
faire leur plein d'essence un français
sur quatre ne mange pas à sa faim des
français renoncent quand même non
beaucoup quand même enfin en tout cas
les gens que les gens - la voix les plus
modestes mais pas que les plus modestes
je pense que des familles arrivent à
avoir du mal à faire face à leurs
dépenses quotidiennes mais le bon levier
pas parce que justement ça touche tout
le monde mais que du coup il ya une
certaine égalité et que tout le monde
fait son plein d'essence et ce avec
typiquement il ya la ruralité par
exemple gérons n'a pas exactement le
même les mails mêmes dépenses d'essence
si vous habitez à 30 km de votre lieu de
travail à ça je crois qu'il ya sept
personnes sur dix qui ont besoin de leur
voiture pour travailler et cette
personne de ces sept personnes
travaillent à plus de 40 km de leur lieu
d'habitation donc voilà et c'est pas
forcément exactement les mêmes besoins
que nous retrouvons en ville tente la
baisse de tva pour bien cadrer les
choses en aurait autant des temporaires
c'est le ski est temporaire c'est la
baisse de tva 0% fin sur le panier
seulement tant que l'inflation est
supérieure d'un ralliement à la
croissance way dernier petit point que
je voulais des bars et effective de la
tva c'est encadré par bruxelles par des
directives européennes
normalement c'est bon vous aurez un
accord avec bruxelles a ramené de 20 à
décideurs en fait personne ne peut
douter de la volonté politique de marine
le pen d'aller justement négocié à
bruxelles le fait qu'il faille donner de
l'air au français laurent saint martin
alors c'est une mesure qui fait parler
des français les simples à comprendre l
et touche tout le monde vous vous avez
fait autre chose le choix des manuels
macron cette baissé de 18 centimes
d'euros le litre d'essence à la pompe a
fait un gain j'ai calculé de 7 euros 20
pour un plein de 40 litres c'est ce qui
inquiète marine le pen elle c'est 8
euros les 40 litres en moins à payer
c'est pas rien vous c'est certain mais
il ya plein d'autres mesure où on va y
revenir mais pourquoi vous y touchez pas
à la tva d'abord on peut pas totalement
commencer ce débat on les sent dire de
telles contre vérités sur la la hausse
ou la baisse du pouvoir d'achat sur ces
cinq dernières années et qu'il regardait
les meilleurs économistes et ce par
exemple pour démontrer que le pouvoir
d'achat augmenter pour l'ensemble de nos
concitoyens les riches et pauvres est
bien d'accord on va en parler avec vos
mesures effectivement plus sur ces cinq
dernières années que cela n'a jamais été
le cas sur lesquels cada précédente déjà
partant sur des bases neige là dessus je
ne vous ai pas coupé merci la deuxième
chose c'est l'inefficacité des mesures
que propose madame le pen et on pourrait
les prendre une vous savez en cas d
organiser ce débat
s'engage à hauteur du budget j'ai vu des
centaines et des centaines d'amendements
proposant la baisse de tva ou
l'annulation de la tva sur plein de
produits différents pendant ces cinq ans
le problème ce qu'il faut dire aux
français c'est que ça ne marche pas ça
ne marche pas pour deux raisons et je
passe outre effectivement le caractère
complexe voire impossible vis-à-vis des
directives européennes apparemment
si vous vous laissez aller au bout de ma
phrase vous expliquer la tva
c'est l'intermédiaire le distributeur le
producteur vous savez comment ça
fonctionne qui peu ou pas répercuté
s'abaisse qui s'appelle la transmission
prix en général à chaque fois que ça a
été fait ça a été fait chez les
restaurateurs en 2009 sous nicolas
sarkozy ça a été fait sur beaucoup de
biens dits de première nécessité déjà la
transmission prix d'environ 10% sur le
consommateur final c'est ce qui est
globalement démontrer c'est pour ça que
quand marine le pen dit que pour 3,6
milliards d'euros elle veut baisser la
tva voire l'annuler sur certains biens
nous l'avons calculer si on prend 10% de
transmission vers le consommateur c'est
à peu près 13 euros par ménage par an
c'est ça le guen source
regardez non mais quelque chose parce
que déjà lu sur le fond ni dissimuler
pas 3,6 à leur arrivée à madame dans le
programme de madame le pen police et
trois
sur le sur le cac mid 100 produits c'est
ça je vous le serait si ce n'est sur les
8 milliard + 6 milliards d'euros adam si
vous voulez parler du programme de la
candidate ont globalement à priori je
lui je le connais je suis aussi la cca
moment là de la part de madame le pen à
elle parce qu'ils étaient jamais à la
6eme mais par rapport à d'autres députés
je les ai vus pendant cinq ans on
accorde pendant cinq ans j'ai démontré
que ce genre d'initiative de baisse ou
d'annulation de tva ça ne servait pas le
consommateur comme ça qu'on a déterminé
s'il vous plaît par contre je voulais à
venir les hermines mgr vis-à-vis des
finances publiques parce qu'on peut pas
terminer je vous en prie laurence
lamarque choisi je vous en prie vous
avez terminé alors est ce que c'est vrai
qui a raison mathieu plane premièrement
sur la répercussion prix est sur le coup
alors il ya deux choses je pense qu'il
faut quand même distinguer la baisse de
tva sur l'énergie de celle sur les
produits première nécessité je pense que
sur l'énergie ça pose plein de questions
y compris sur son coût sur sa
possibilité est compris dans le cadre
des directives européennes sur les faits
du signal prix également et qui va
profiter le plus de cette baisse de tva
parce qu'on voit que c'est aussi ce qui
vont consommer le plus d'énergie qu'ils
vont profiter le plus de cette bd y
compris des gens qui ont des gros
véhicules qui ne prend pas qu'ils ne
font pas d'efforts prendre des
transports en commun donc c'est assez
mal ciblés pour vous et puis dans le
temps ça coûte cher que ça coûte très
cher parce que c'est ce milliard 12
milliards par an de façon pérenne donc
ça pose la question de son financement
de la compatibilité avec la transition
énergétique quand même parce que ça crée
aussi des incitations à recourir plutôt
à
du coup au pétrole est donc plutôt qu'à
d'autres formes notamment de d'énergie
ses premiers points mais après sur les
biens de première nécessité c'est plus
compliqué alors après il faudrait
connaître le cadre d'une pratique
c'est vrai que la transmission se fait
pas intégralement ça on le sait qu' une
partie dans les baisses de tva qui sont
captés par les marges des producteurs
les distributeurs ou léon distributeurs
mais difficile à mesurer c'est vrai qu'à
court terme c'est pas forcément
répercuté intégralement maintenant il
faut voir comment c'est fait en termes
de diffusion il ya quand même deux
choses qui sont qui pose question c'est
à dire qu'elle est ce panier en c'est
vrai et puis la marche finalement et de
5% en réalité un parce qu'on a déjà
allée bien deux premiers des biens de
première nécessité sont taxés à 5 et
demi pour cent des rendez vous rue de
rennes qui permettrait de les faire à
zéro donc j'allais dire plutôt c'est que
le gain serait assez limité et puis
après au sein des produits même de
première nécessité et des grandes
différences sur les marques en fait vous
avez des biens de certains biens qui
sont de grande consommation qui coûtent
peu cher et puis vous avez même en fait
y compris dans les biens de première
nécessité dans l'alimentaire des biens
qui sont plutôt de luxe donc tout le
monde va en profiter en réalité sans
qu'il y ait de distinctions alors vous
allez je dirais plutôt que en fait en
réalité sur le pouvoir d'achat l'impact
serait relativement limitée dans cette
limite d'âge vous regardez garder vos
humiliations du pâtissier j'aimerais
terminer ce tour de table dominique
ceaux ya une chose aussi je sais pas
très écolo quand même c'est quand même
un vin à table argument là on se dit que
la baisse de la tva va une durable sur
au moins la période d'inflation qui
vient peut-être après sur sur le fuel
surtout les hydrocarbures ans l'aide du
gaz et puis dessins sélectionnés le
souci de lutter contre le réchauffement
climatique on doit penser qu' il est
normal que les prix des carburants
augmentent pour les français qui peuvent
se le payer tous les français ne sont
pas pauvres tous les français n'ont pas
d'effets allemand épouvantablement
difficile et c'est vrai que les études
qui ont été faites sur l'évolution du
pouvoir ces dernières années les études
sont des études mais elles sont
convergentes et c'est franchement je
n'avais jamais vu dans ma carrière de
journaliste était lasse un peu longue je
n'avais jamais vu d'étude aussi
convergentes qu'elle vienne soit 2 le fc
eu de l'insee du trésor l'institut des
politiques publiques qui montrent que
pour la quasi totalité des français en
tout cas par là pour la quasi-totalité
des centile de revenus ça veut pas dire
pour tous les français mais la majorité
des français le pouvoir d'achat a
augmenté alors c'est vrai qu'on peut se
dire comment ça se fait qu'on entende à
vos micros devant vos caméras
voilà les c'est le ressenti c'est vrai
quand on interroge généralement plus les
français sur n'ont pas calé vote pouvoir
d'achat et comment voter at il augmenté
mais quel est votre ressenti et c'est
normal que le ressenti aujourd'hui on a
besoin on a réellement besoin de
davantage de services et de biens qui a
dix ou quinze ans en tout cas on
considère que le minimum vital c est
différent mais néanmoins il est un
contexte d'inflation et c'est pour ça
que la réponse outre la question du du
réchauffement climatique est une baisse
non discriminer de tva sur le prix de
l'énergie par est à la fois contre
historique sur le plan du réchauffement
climatique est extrêmement coûteuse pour
bénéficier à une efficacité
beaucoup de griefs ça fait ça fait quand
même se rendre à la baisse même liste de
10 centimes à la pompe c'est aussi ça
qui est intéressant oui mais là vote
votre baisse de 18
elle va si elle va se prolonger jusqu'à
la fin de l'année jusqu'à le nez 2023
qu'avant les dix mots nettement elles et
les noms ciblés aussi elle a exactement
le message ça c'est vrai à l'est de
l'allemagne de la même manière pour
toutes les personnes restant vraiment
c'est que vous aviez vous été difficile
à tout le monde c'est vrai mais elle a
un impact immédiat
vous l'avez probablement vu vous même si
vous avez fait le plein récemment ça a
un impact immédiat à la pomme ne l'avez
pas vous n'avez pas sur tous les
interdits et c'est plus facile
d'empêcher
cela c'est le poids d'achat c'est les
hausses de salaires et la question sur
les rives
c est ce que le rassemblement national à
des
alliés ou en tout cas des syndicats qui
voudront être dans le même bateau pour
revendiquer auprès des entreprises parce
que c'est la solution du pouvoir d'achat
ce sont les salaires mais qu'il n'a pas
d'argent l'état il est endetté
dans la vallée je vais bientôt prendre
ta question ça va pas être sérieux la
question de l'efficacité prix ouais et à
la question écologique
et puis à la question du coût simplement
avec une pour répond tout à l'heure ce
que vous disiez puisque j'ai le
programme souvenez c'est une toute
petite phrase suspension de la tva sur
un panier de 100 produits de première
nécessité pour l'alimentation l'hygiène
nous avons évalué cette mesure à 8,6
milliards par an permettant de rendre 25
euros par mois 300 par an aux ménages et
jeu effectivement je me confronte aux
rapports c'est le programme de marine le
pen et du compas trop lourd sur le
programme en question dont vous parlez
par le programme et le rapport dont vous
parlez j'aimerais bien que vous me
donniez enfin on sait très bien que
l'organisme qui a sorti le ce dont vous
me parliez s'éteint c'est un soutien
emmanuel macron donc moi aussi je peux
demander à plein de mes potes non mais
oui
pas de vous
pendant cinq ans le cabinet mckinsey
vous avez des experts la septième de
vous dire que la tradition prix et échos
sur l'objet
dans le débat mais chez myers huit
jeunes ont même baissé à lèvres pourquoi
j'invite conflits d'intérêts dans la mc
- dit excusez moi mais là j'en doute
je
te suis je suis une femme s'adresse à
des aléas
de première nécessité et tout à l'heure
vous entendez parler effectivement de en
fait vous savez en province on n'est pas
tous sur des trottinettes électriques
les gens ont besoin aussi de la voiture
la voiture n'est pas un luxe quand vous
dites ça va inciter à prendre sa voiture
mais en fait la majorité
de prendre
ne pas inciter par exemple s'avère que
dans la transition énergétique c'est
compliqué de faire baisser les prix des
énergies les plus polluantes où est ce
qu'on va prendre les recettes qu'ils y
aller car si c'est justement si c'est
pas les trajets la voiture pour la
majorité défend ce que je dis c'est que
dans une réponse structurelle il vaut
mieux cibler les ménages modestes qui
sont dépendants énergétiquement ça coûte
moins cher et c'est plus efficace en
réalité ça mais c'est une mesure
structurelle moi ce que je dis aussi
c'est que là la réponse du gouvernement
actuel est à peu près similaire mais
elle est censée être transitoire mais la
question c'est qu'est ce qui se passe
après vers vous avez raison mais juste à
la étaient complémentaires
luxe jeunes en jeu c'est jon province si
je sais ce que tu as été la remise à la
pompe il faut le préciser a été
complémentaires de l'indemnité inflation
notamment elle même étant si les sur les
revenus de moins de 1000 euros donc vous
avez raison de préciser que c'est pour
tout le monde sauf que c'était au
complément de mesures et 18 centimes
commence le mécanisme pour comprendre
c'est de l'argent moi ça on a compris
dans les caisses de l'état il va les
prendre ou au départ c'est 18 centimes 1
cc directement aux pétroliers comment
comment ça fonctionne bien sûr que des
compensations des compensations directes
c'est ça à la fin c'est les finances
publiques qui fait ça m'a pris je vous
le confiner la tva c'est facile à
comprendre la laitance que c'était bien
encore une fois sans pardon pardon
d'insister la tva c'est juste pas
possible de le faire comme ça et marine
le pen a dit plusieurs fois j'ai bien
écouté que cela être fait dès le 25 au
matin de cette eau pure mensonge quoi
parce qu'on nous poussait dans la tva
sont passés devant le parlement petit
temps et puis c'est sans pensée et sans
oublier et sans prendre en considération
toutes les problématiques de droit
européen qui apparemment n'existe pas
dans le meilleur des merveilleux monde
du racing va parler justement vous avez
commencé à égréner les mesures du
président candidat de pouvoir d'achat
côté emmanuel macron puis on continuera
à égrainer l'autre d'autres mesures tour
d'horizon signé stéphanie des pierres
sur le pouvoir d'achat le candidat
macron défend d'abord le bilan du
président macron l'indemnité inflation
le bouclier tarifaire sur l'énergie la
réduction de 18 centimes à la pompe
emmanuel macron le martèle cela
représente beaucoup 20 milliards d'euros
par an mais il sait que ça ne suffit pas
toujours je ne me résoudrai jamais à ce
que des français qui travaillent
voit tout leur salaire partir en plein
d'essence en factures au loyer alors ils
s'engagent à prolonger le bouclier
énergétique et le rabais sur les 106 les
prix continuent de flamber pour alléger
le ticket de caisse il vient aussi de
dégainer un shack alimentaire aux
contours encore flous pour réduire la
facture fiscale il supprimera la
redevance télé pour doper la fiche de
paie il n'y aura pas de coup de pouce au
smic le candidat veut mettre le patronat
à contribution en triplant la prime
macron déjà existantes le vrai pouvoir
d'achat c'est celui qui vient du travail
qui est durable par lequel quand on
travaille on gagne plus c'est pourquoi
dès cet été je veux permettre aux
travailleurs de pouvoir toucher une
prime de pouvoir d'achat allant jusqu'à
6000 euros sans charges ni impôt une
prime qui n'a rien d'obligatoire
ce sera donc au bon vouloir des
entreprises pour les retraités emmanuel
macron promet une pension minimum à 1100
euros et surtout le retour de
l'indexation sur l'inflation dès cet été
enfin et c'est une mesure de pouvoir
d'achat selon le candidat il veut
réduire les droits de succession il n'y
aura plus d'impôts jusqu'à cent
cinquante mille euros par enfant si
emmanuel macron irait lui alors on va
parler du vrai pouvoir d'achat selon
emmanuel macron vous avez fait en commun
d'ailleurs de dire qu'au fond c'est le
salaire qui doit être le levier
principal mais pour continuer la
discussion sur les mesures d'urgence
jusqu'à quand c'est à dire les 18
centimes le bouclier tarifaire le
blocage des prix et où vous vous trouvez
les 20 à 30 milliards d'euros par an
nécessaires non d'abord jusqu'à compte
tant qu'il le faudra mais tant qu
effectivement des conséquences notamment
de la guerre en ukraine qui ont pris le
relais sur les conséquences
inflationnistes de de la relance après
la crise qu'ovide seront là donc
probablement encore assez longtemps la
grande différence pardon à votre
question où les trouver c'est que nous
notre programme il est totalement
financé parce qu'il ya des recettes en
face et des vraies recettes la réforme
des retraites courageuses et difficiles
à faire mais dont nous savons qu'elles
le meilleur levier budgétaire pour
pouvoir financer nous aident à financer
la dépendance des tas de choses ça va
financer d'abord le système de retraite
est lui un certain nombre de nouvelles
solidarités et aussi le pouvoir d'achat
des français évidemment et puis la
croissance et le travail c'est bon pour
le voir d'achat des français parce que
c'est leur salaire qui est en jeu c'est
aussi bon pour les finances de l'état
les recettes fiscales les recettes
sociales qui permettent à leur tour de
financer soit les besoins de modèle
social soit des services publics et si
vous regardez bien les programmes et
j'invite vraiment tout le monde a bien
regardé le programme il y a un programme
qui est financée avec 50 milliards
d'euros de dépenses nouvelles à 2027
financé par 50 milliards d'euros soit de
recettes nouvelles soit de moindres
dépenses celui de madame le pen c'est
100 milliards de plus son déficit à la
fin de son mandat et elle est élue temps
qu'il faut regarder ça c'est important
je ne vous honnêtement je ne vous fais
pas le reproche de vouloir augmenter le
pouvoir d'achat des français mais je
pense que ces lois ou là les mêmes chez
joue à la
différence est pas et donc c'est pas ça
le fait quand même ballot et puis
excusez moi mais le mal je ne sais pas
mais le mot c'est ballot excusez moi
c'est c'est dommage je sais les mozart
de la finance vous ne me laissez un
quinquennat avec 600 milliards de dettes
et vous allez nous expliquer que tout
est chiffré alors déjà valu de faire
leur coiffe ils ont encore une fois ah
bah forcément je sais pas est ce que
vous l'avez fait par exemple pour
l'allocation adulte handicapé ça va les
600000 et si si si ça vous fait des
écoutes mais je sais pas pas comme ça je
pense mais bon il fallait vous savez je
pense que nous aurions une une politique
tout à fait différent dans cette gestion
du duc au village en deux parts avec
deux livres en cyclo rocky denny chin la
santé met vraiment à la salle il fallait
faire le coq il en coûte madame le
pénible ces routes et donc j'ai fait si
vous avez la même arrogance que votre
précision
de plus rock et les deux semaines on en
championnat qui ont été enfin rouvrir le
débat ce sont vos soutiens et ça ne leur
demandez
vous voulez dominique ce nom mais
n'existe pas comme ça je pense pas que
je pense qu'on a les armes pour 10 / / /
les prix garantis par l'état il convient
à nos supporters c'est le fauteuil pge
les entreprises sont en train de
l'entamé il vaut à lui seul chef
d'entreprise excusez moi qui vais plus
j'ai fait il à lui demande s'il vous
plaît nous fait enlever bas sur ces voir
la chasse à ceux qui nous regardent on
essaye de les aider arrogant madame
lavalley vous faites ça ou si vous
choisissez monsieur saint martin c'est
là s'il vous plaît as comme ça se fait
le jour et la macro ni s'il vous plaît
s'il vous plaît on va remettre un tout
petit peu de sérénité dominique seux
c'est intéressant parce que sur les
salaires là on a deux candidats a priori
très opposés mais qui ont la même
approche aucun des deux devait augmenter
le smic et ils nous disent tous les deux
au fond le pouvoir d'achat etc c'est le
travail il faut inciter par des baisses
de charges diverses et variées prix
macron d'un côté baisses de charges pour
obtenir des hausses de salaire de
l'autre ça ça peut marcher de toute
façon ce sont des entreprises qui vont
augmenter les salaires mais est ce que
ces incitations là peuvent être
efficaces alors c'est ce qui se fait
depuis des dizaines d'années de baisser
les cotisations sociales patronales pour
les cotisations sociales payées par les
entreprises pour augmenter le salaire
net après la question à mon avis dans
les années dans l'année qui vient ça va
être est ce que les entreprises doivent
augmenter de toute façon les salaires et
la réponse est oui la réponse est oui
c'est à dire qu'avec une inflation qui
tourne autour de 4% il est absolument
inévitable et bienvenu que les
entreprises signent des accords
c'est déjà un peu le cas depuis le mois
de novembre type aime tant la hauteur
pas pas à la hauteur dans la quasi
totalité des branches vous avez des
salaires qui augmentent disons deux et
demi et 3 % ce qui est ce qui est un
super géant pas mal non
on note pas assez c'est un vrai
changement par rapport au quinze ou
vingt ans qui viennent de s'écouler
d'occident les entreprises que ça va se
passer est-ce que les d'une manière ou
d'une autre par des alizés allègement de
questions sociales il faut inciter au
mouvement la réponse est oui là il ya
différentes primes april may compte
replay 10 différents ateliers s'en
charge attention néanmoins à ne pas
priver les caisses de sécurité sociale
de recettes quand même
question
la question
attendez vous allez répondre à un enjeu
enfin des enjeux de court terme et de
long terme sort qu'on est face à un choc
énergétique est très particulier la
question c'est est-ce qui va durer si
dur ça change quand même beaucoup de
choses c'est à dire qu'effectivement on
va voir qu'il y aura quand même beaucoup
de perdants ça pose la question aussi
des méthode d'indexation c'est à dire on
voit par exemple les retraites vont être
indexé enfin je sais que ces deux
propositions tout cas lire indique c'est
plus vite le team italien a dicté par
exemple mais ça pose la question de
toute la hiérarchie des salaires qui
sont pas indexés qui sont négociés dans
l'entreprise donc ça veut dire que même
si le salaire augmente si par exemple
l'inflation à 5 % avec le segment 2 3%
salariés encaissent une perte de points
d'achat donc fait d'avoir
très peu de marge de manoeuvre en
réalité un là dessus et donc ça c'est
vrai qu'il faut faire attention quand on
parle de hausses de salaires c'est
qu'elle ose de salaire par rapport à
l'inflation donc série dans un premier
temps c'est quand même malheureusement
ce choc énergétique c'est une perte de
poids d'achat pour la france parce qu'on
produit pas d'hydrocarbures et donc
forcément ça nous coûte plus cher à
auxerre il ya conjoncture ça va durer
combien de temps et donc le problème
c'est dans la conjoncture vous êtes vous
fait pas de la géopolitique et donc
c'est combien de temps va durer le
conflit en ukraine les rapports avec la
russie est ce que rana un embargo par
exemple avril le 25e riz à l'embargo est
évidemment oui
le champion non sur le gaz russe en
europe alors oui c'est que justement le
positionnement sur le pétrole le
français encore déclaré aujourd'hui
favorable à un embargo sur
le gaz
c'est juste après le substitut
pour l'heure la valeur rallye c'est le
poids d'achat ça renvoie forcément une
question plus macro économique parce que
si vous voulez si vous n'avez pas plus
de croissance vous pouvez pas
redistribué puissant que ça veut dire
sous les données du port achat il faut
prendre quelques parts soit si vous
prenez sur les riches et vous redonner
aux plus modestes soit vous reprenez sur
les entreprises pour donner aux ménages
soit vous faites du déficit en fait et
donc c'est bien là la complexité c'est
que globalement il n'y a pas de recette
est là en tendance la croissance est le
commerce investissement
de la croissance se pose la question de
ce partage des revenus du poids d'achat
des inégalités effectivement le choc
énergétique créé beaucoup d'inégalités
parce qu'on n'est pas exposé de la même
façon à l'énergie selon nous sont
situation
sylvie si les revenus sont
malheureusement des difficultés en
français aussi que la france globalement
ne travaille pas c'est absolument nous
sommes le pays dans tous les pays de la
cedeao y compris en zone euro qui
travaillent collectivement le moins je
parle pas des salariés à temps complet
je parle si on prend l'ensemble des
heures travaillées en france et le
nombre de français on divise vous êtes
ainsi 130 heures par an et par français
là c'est un fait
les retraites oui alors prime macron
triplé sans charger sans impôts pourquoi
c'est mieux qu'une incitation par la
baisse des charges d'abord la baisse des
charges elle a été fait pendant ces cinq
années sauf des mousses suppression du
cic au remplacement par baisses de
charges patronales pérenne durable donc
ça ça a été fait pendant ce mandat après
c'est un équilibre les charges vous
savez les cotisations comme vous l'avez
très bien dit c'est fait pour financer
des risques et donc vous pouvez pas les
baisser totalement et donc il faut bien
aussi financer notre modèle social tant
que la prime macron comptent triple et
qu'on pérennise elle a ceci de vertueux
c'est que ça crée un nouvel outil de
partage de la valeur pour les salariés
on connaissait l'intéressement on
connaissait la participation et beaucoup
d'entreprises notamment les petites ne
savait pas mettre en place des outils
seraient macro et y en aura beaucoup
dans des petites souris parce que cette
grosse boîte non justement c'est plutôt
le petit parce que c'est très facile à
mettre en place et les députés son
employeur par exemple et on met en place
les prix de macron pour les
collaborateurs du parlement et donc
c'est très facile pour les petites
équipes de le mettre en place et le
principe qu emmanuel macron veut
vraiment mettre de façon intangible dans
ce pays désormais c'est quand vous
distribuer des dividendes à vos
actionnaires ce qui est normal revenus
du capital eh bien vous devez
systématiquement maintenant aussi
distribuer du dividende salariés soit la
participation soit le revêtement de la
valeur plutôt
sur la prime alors je sais pas je vais
me tourner vers les experts mais a aussi
un effet un peu pervers de cette prime
c'est que ça peut aussi inciter les
chefs d'entreprise par exemple à baisser
un peu les salaires et de compenser avec
les primes non de face et dans les
entreprises les entreprises suivent
quand même des accords de branche vous
baissez pas les salaires comme ça et en
plus vous pouvez le bruit de ces illégal
quand même un effet pervers là dessus et
sinon effectivement nous on ne monte pas
le smic mais on propose on ans seulement
et de hausse de 10 points vous aider
d'entreprise interrogés sur sa baignoire
jean luc mélenchon proposé une hausse du
smic on explique que nous on nous
propose l'augmentation de tous les
salaires dans l'entreprise de 10%
jusqu'à 3 fois le smic mais c'est pas
beaucoup c'est pas vous qui proposait
l'augmentation il faut dire la vérité
serait bien si on proposait mai
sous ce ciel le fond oui je n'ai rien à
l'entreprise donc on peut imaginer qu
effectivement le patron puisse augmenter
de façon
à les états non non à la question qui se
pose c'est redonner du pouvoir d'achat
effectivement il ya le les gains de
parts d'achat qui peuvent être immédiat
par des exonérations de cotisations ou
certaines primes mais se pose la
question effectivement des droits
accumulés aussi c'est à dire que le la
retraite c'est un revenu finalement
différé des cotisations vous payez donc
c'est vrai qu'il ya toujours cette
question est-ce que ça va se substituer
aux salaires ou les exonérations de
cotisations vous poser le problème du
financement de la protection sociale
c'est ce
qui est vrai c'est que les sondages ont
montré que 56 % des dirigeants
d'entreprises ont voté pour votre
candidate au premier tour l'élection
présidentielle et 1,7 alors que ce soit
que ce soit évidemment c'est toutes
tailles ces artisans commerçants mais
c'est vrai donc c'est la raison pour
laquelle vous n'augmentez pas les suit
naturellement
mesures précédemment a séduit les
patrons de tpe pme on va terminer ce
débat par une mesure qui fait couler
beaucoup d'encre la proposition de
marine le pen d'exonérer d'impôt sur le
revenu les jeunes jusqu'à 30 ans vous
entendez des interrogations et des
critiques depuis plusieurs semaines aux
fonds déjà les des jeunes ya mba paix
mais les jeunes au fond on commence à
des salaires très modeste donc en
général sont peu imposable voire pas du
tout est ce qu'elle est vraiment juste
cette mesure elle est juste et puis je
pense que c'est une façon de miser sur
la jeunesse aussi de ne pas avoir envie
que la jeunesse qui gagne aussi de
l'argent s'en aille à l'étranger et
c'est aussi miser sur des chefs
d'entreprise sur la recherche sur la
réindustrialisation
je dirais c'est une mesure de pouvoir
d'achat mais aussi je veux dire de ont
misé sur la jeunesse pour redonner à la
france aussi un tissu un tissu de la
valeur travail important et oui à ce
moment là on a le droit jusqu'à 30 enfin
mba pc info enfin je trouve franchement
que c'est un faux exemple les bébés ne
consomme ni dénommé les aigles a fait ne
court pas à la rue non plus voulu dire
ou alors
ap ap joue la corde par contre il ya
beaucoup de personnes de moins de 30 ans
j'en ai fais partie qui ont bien gagner
leur vie dans leurs premières années
après les études et qui doivent payer
l'impôt sur le revenu qui est la
nôtre mais j'aime bien votre projet
totalement injuste ça veut dire que vous
assumez pardon vous assumer qu'un
ouvrier de 50 ans doit payer de l'impôt
sur le revenu mais pas un cadre
financier de la défense de 29 ans les
assumer mais on a le droit de penser que
nous on a envie de miser sur cette
jeunesse vous vous êtes pas vous avez
bien vu qu'elle est un exode mais si la
partie des livres des enfants étudiants
je vois bien que la plupart de deux de
leurs copains et d'une wild card info ce
dont ils ont envie de partir beaucoup je
pense que c'est une façon pour des
raisons fiscales à l'impôt sur les gens
là
si la grande majorité madame des jeunes
notamment des moins de 25 ans ne paient
pas d'impôts sur le revenu et ceux qui
commencent à gagner un peu d'argent
entre 25 et 30 ans en paye et ceux qui
en payent beaucoup doivent en payer
beaucoup parce qu'ils gagnent beaucoup
d'argent donc décidé de projet étude
mesure parce que elle a bien percolé qui
peut avoir son avantage dans un
programme je vous le reconnaît ça
s'appelle
s'appelle une bonne mesure démago mais
surtout ça s'appelle une mesure pas d'un
traitement injuste socialement parce que
vous privez d'impôts ce qui doivent en
payer est par contre ça c'est sur le dos
de ceux et continuant payer à être et ne
sont pas dans les première tranche de
l'impôt sur le revenu même si on l'a
baissé qui eux vont voir les moins de 30
ans de plus ont payés ça n'a aucun sens
mais c'était certainement le verrou
constitutionnel
on pense que s'asseoir sur la
constitution vous l'avez vous l'avez
d'ailleurs subi cette
inconstitutionnalité avec la taxe
d'habitation la taxe d'habitation
puisque vous avez d'abord dit il faut
pour 80% supprimer la taxe d'habitation
concessionnels vous a dit dans les amis
ça passe pas donc vous devrez non
seulement de nerf à lui après et andré
ça coûte effectivement très cher il n'a
pas censuré sur les 80 % à jour précise
une âme à 100 sur lumes non mais il a
dit faut il faut étendre souffert de ma
barre
de l'égalité il est français de
s'asseoir sur le conseil constitutionnel
ce qui pose quand même un problème et on
peut vous pouvez considérer il faut
s'asseoir là-dessus ça pose un problème
sur le plan c'est vrai de l'égalité
c'est un peu curieux de vouloir
absolument exonérés d'impôt sur le
revenu les consultants de mckinsey de
moins de 30 ans la jeunesse a prêté par
exemple les siens on pourrait en parler
la réforme de la retraite qui pour le
coup pourrait votre nom n'est pas
l'objet de ce débours évidemment pas
fait c'est fini un cadre de mathias et
raleigh de neil
mathieu bon après il y aurait beaucoup
de choses à dire sur l'impôt sur le
revenu il ya un vrai problème de ciblage
parce qu'effectivement ce qu'ils paient
beaucoup d'impôts sur le revenu sont
ceux qui ont des belles carrières déjà
d'entrée de jeu donc ce qu'on fait tous
des belles études oncle charlie qui
viennent de familles plutôt aisées jédir
6 à 3 milliards ahmed je les mettrai pas
sur ces jeunes là voilà c'est juste ma
conclusion moi je n'avais juste les gens
aiment la france pour un point à faire
pour montrer bien que ce projet je vous
assure et chiffré on l'a pas écrit sur
un coin de table figurez vous qu'on a
des économies pour aller je dois aller
du tout et
auront les clés pour aborder le débat
d'entre deux tours de main je fais quand
on a 600 milliards de dettes je suis
d'accord on n'est plus à ça près merci
ce débat sur le quoi qu'il en coûte vous
la technique vous
laisser débattre en dehors de ce studio
ce débat est terminé merci j'espère que
vous avez pu y voir un peu plus clair
sur les mesures voilà qui évidemment on
voit bien les lignes de fracture vous
sépare pour le pouvoir d'achat grandes
priorités des français merci infiniment
merci merci madame on va accueillir à
présent notre grand témoin son histoire
celle d'un écrivain réfugiés politiques
syriens nous éclaire vous allez voir
plus que jamais sur le prix de la
démocratie a voté pour la première fois
en france au premier tour de la
présidentielle dans un pays rongé par
l'abstention et le désenchantement
souvent alors il raconte dans son
dernier roman les premiers pas d'un
jeune exilé entre paris et bobigny qui
se retrouvent confrontés à ce qui la
fuit le fanatisme religieux il s'appelle
omar youssef souleymane et son portrait
signé thibault et n'a qu'à regarder
si on vous invite au mario sève
souleimane c'est que le 10 avril dernier
vous avez entendu ces mots
et que la résonance qui l'ont tuée en
vous c'était bouleversant est incroyable
j'avais fait la fête doit nous donner à
réfléchir nous pour qu'ils sont devenus
une aveugle habitudes omar youssef
souleymane vous êtes journaliste poète
écrivain réfugiés syriens arrivés en
france il ya dix ans naturalisée depuis
peu vous raconter dans vos livres votre
parcours de l'islamisme salafistes dans
lequel votre enfance à baigner à
l'athéisme de damas à bobigny de la
tyrannie à la liberté on y croit je ne
comprends pas pour quelle raison on a ce
qu'on appelle la démocratie et on en
profite pas manifestés en dix ans ni
macro ni le pen ça je ne comprends pas
c'est absurde mob être ni macro ni
l'open il faut vraiment choisir pour
théo avoir la liberté d'expression c'est
aussi une chance
sur deux privilèges liberté se moque
elle vous associez la france est un
célèbre poème de paul eluard je suis né
pour
libérer cette liberté que nous avons
cessé de voir vous nous la montre et
vous l'interrogez aussi tout comme ce
pays devenu votre pays où tout est
possible où tout est permis mais
traversé de tensions de zones d'ombré
que vous racontez dans votre dernier
livre ainsi de la réalité des banlieues
que vous découvrez à bobigny et la
radicalisation par exemple filles et de
nos banques et voilée à bobigny même en
syrie on voit ben hassan sauf dans
certains villages de fanatiques pourquoi
ça existe dans un pays laïc comme la
france un visage de la france qui vous
choque vous qui avez fui cet
obscurantisme
vous qui connaissez ces mécaniques
d'endoctrinement mieux que quiconque car
elles ont failli faire de vous un
terroriste quand vous étiez adolescent
j'aurais voté cet essor de au mondial de
licence comment j'étais
vraiment mon rêve en attendant faut
jouer au paradis cet adolescent c'est
vraiment c'était un voyage de la
religion
scan l'athéisme vous vous inquiétez
ainsi de voir la france péché par
naïveté est appelé à défendre la laïcité
et la liberté d'expression sans
concession alors omar youssef souleimane
en ce mois d'avril 2022 depuis votre
chambre en exil ou est toujours accroché
le mot liberté scandé par l ua au bout
de votre voyage que voyez-vous à cinq
jours du second tour de la
présidentielle
que diriez-vous un français qui
s'apprêtent à s'abstenir la france est
elle une belle endormie notre pays
devrait il clamé plus haut ses valeurs
bonsoir omar youssef souleymane et merci
beaucoup d'avoir accepté notre
invitation vous avez 35 ans vous êtes
écrivain vous êtes poète aussi une
chambre en exil c'est à dire chez
flammarion c'est votre sixième roman
vous écrivait en français
et puis depuis peu vous êtes vous-même
français puisque vous avez été
naturalisés ça vous a permis de voter
pour la première fois le 10 avril
dernier à l'élection présidentielle a
d'abord comment vous avez vécu ce moment
là et qu'est ce qu'il a représenté pour
vous c'était un moment bouleversant
j'étais très ému le soir même c'était
champaigne fonds pour moi c'était
vraiment la fête vous savez ces cas on
vient d'un pays est dirigé par un régime
dictatorial est ce que ça vous dire
quelle valeur de pointe et en syrie ont
voté toujours bien sûr on et c'était
obligatoire de voter pour notre
président qui va rester président pour
toujours
comme comme comme on disait rapport les
les services de renseignement c'est à
dire le père du président actuel avec la
scène ils gagnaient à
95 95 99 parfois au parfois même à 100%
pour al fils tout à fait le beau char
araud a pris le pouvoir donc voté pour
moi c'était cela vous dire participer à
l'avenir de mon nouveau pays la france
et c'était une grande valeur et honore
aussi et le contraste alors avec cette
phrase qui se réfugient dans
l'abstention parfois même dans le le
rejet vous le comprenez ce désintérêt en
france on ne mesure pas notre chance en
fait au début c'était à me priver
c'était tellement choquant pour moi de
retrouver cette radicalisation de
laquelle on a fouillé depuis la série
depuis le moyen orient de retrouver ce
type de violence de malentendus surtout
dans la banlieue parisienne où j'ai
essayé d'en parler troisième roman une
chambre en exil et donc pour le réfugié
qui a fui d'eau douce au monde cette
ambiance il se demander tout le temps et
pourquoi pourquoi une fille de 9 ans et
voilée pourquoi et à ce type d imam
radical qui essaie de manipuler les
musulmans où on va on va venir à votre
parcours et à cette ville de bobigny où
vous avez vécu et c'est là que vous vous
tomber de haut parce que dans la france
des lumières il ya aussi des fillettes
voilées alors quand on arrive de syrie
avec votre trajectoire forcément c'est
choquant vous avez grandi entre l'arabie
saoudite et la syrie dans une famille
musulmane salafistes vous avez raconté
tout ça dans un livre qui s'appelle le
petit terroriste qui avait fait grand
bruit vous auriez pu vous même basculé
dans le djihad et ça n'a pas été le cas
vous avez fui une forme d'endoctrinement
vous avez été manifestants pendant le
printemps arabe syrien et puis vous avez
fini par choisir d'être athée avant de
vous réfugier en france comment on
bascule de la fois au doute est-ce que
c'est un long cheminement où est-ce
qu'un déclic c'est un long cheminement
cheminement est très difficile et très
compliqué on commence par se poser des
questions pourquoi on est entouré par
cette violence par cette haine par
sos-racisme et à la fois la religion
doit être disons une manière de
ressembler les
de rassembler pardon les gens autour
autour la pensée et un sort de tolérance
pourquoi orias toute cette violence dans
ce pays qui s'appelle l'arabie saudite
donc à partir de cette idée j'ai
commencé d'avoir des doutes contre la
religion contre le texte coranique
contre la borne demeurant mais de
quelles en étaient obligés d'apprendre
par coeur car on était 40 et à l'école à
l'école car j'étais dans un dans une
école coranique en arabie saoudite et
donc les questions amène au doute et les
doutes hier et c'est aussi plein
d'espoir il ya aussi des passages très
très émouvant et est aussi très drôle
dans votre livre vous racontez par
exemple dans le portrait qui vous est
consacré dans libération que lors d'un
pèlerinage familial à la mecque vous
n'avait d'yeux que pour les femmes qui
vous entoure est justement pour ce faire
vous ayez la liberté cdi ou produits
interdits contre les talibans c'est ça
la liberté ça les doutes
pascoe quand on est dix ans en bataille
en soi même entre le désir et l'interdît
entre les tabous et sa liberté
individuelle
finalement il faut choisir donc à ce
moment-là à la mecque pendant le
pèlerinage je me demandais tout le temps
mais pourquoi je n'arrive pas de me
contrôler il arrive d'être contrôlé mon
propre désir vis-à-vis des femmes donc
donc le désir c'est que ça fait partie
de nos et malheureusement la religion
souvent interdisent ce désir le bloc et
nos empêche d'aller donc des réalistes
réaliser ses rêves parce que le rêve
aussi font partie d'un porte qu'elle
aurait fait partie de son propre diane
finley des femmes d'ailleurs dans votre
livre à son importante c'est un peu
votre alter ego que vous mettez en scène
ce réfugié syrien qui essaye aussi de
trouver la femme de sa vie qui
découvrent qu'ils découvrent bobigny ce
qui est assez cruel et en même temps
assez drôle c'est que lorsque vous
arrivez en france vous rencontrer des
filles on pense à personnage d'eva dans
dans le
livres dans des associations d'aidé aux
migrants qui vous accusent de faire le
jeu de l'extrême droite quand vous
dénoncer l'islamisme vous l'accusez
ternel de la part d'une partie de la
gauche française
vous la gauche halal parce que cette
gauche ne pas contente de critiquer de
voir un migrant comme moi qui critique
disons les islamistes en france parce qu
pour cette gauche ces migrants jouent le
jeu de l'extrême droite tandis qu à mon
avis cette gauche a abandonné son devoir
parce que c'est là c'est à la gauche
française de critiquer les islamistes et
tri de la république donc pourquoi vous
avez laissé le terrain alexandre hot
pour a sonné pour réagir à la place de
vos critiques et vous même l'artisan
l'ailé radicale on fera donc ils
accusent le migrant comme moi davo de
faire deux jours de joux est récupéré
par l'extrême droite sauf qu en fait je
pense pas qu'on critique les islamistes
en france quand on convient quand on
vient de cet enfer qui s'appelle les
islamismes surtout au moyen orient non
le contexte français on le critique
parce qu'on a déjà vu mais vous
critiquez parce que vous le connaissez
d'ailleurs il ya des scènes saisissantes
vous n'imaginiez pas croisés à bobigny
des fillettes voilées il ya ce
personnage de violette qui vous faire
rencontrer des imams radicaliser
salafistes vous n'imaginez pas retrouvé
sa jamais en fait imaginer ce que vous
savez en série dans cette petite ville
chaque village on a trois pouvoirs la
haye le policier et l'imam est l'idiot
toujours dans le sens troyes pouvoir qui
n'ont rien à voir avec les trois
pouvoirs français ya aucune séparation
très trop de pouvoir je n'ai jamais
imaginé qu'une dans une ville donc en
bobigny j'allais trouver aussi en sorte
de complicité entre les politiciens et
les imams de la ville et ce n'est pas
seulement à bobigny que tient à préciser
existe dans seine saint denis entre
désir et your absolument entre les
élites et lima et on a pas mal
d'épreuves source sur ce sujet je trouve
que c est dangereux pour pour notre pays
d'ailleurs vous dialoguez dans dans
plusieurs lycées avec la jeunesse
française
musulmane et qu'est ce que vous
comprenez de ses attentes parfois
souvent elle parle du bled comme d'un
paradis perdu qu au fond elle n'a pas
connu puisque cette jeunesse
malheureusement cette jeunesse qui est
né en france qui s'en sort dans leur
propre pays mais quand je les pose la
question par exemple dans durant les at
il été créé toujours avec les gens que
je dirige
dans la banlieue parisienne ou ailleurs
si un problème vous arrivez ici en
france vous allez au la réponse est on
va dans notre pays
sauf qu alors j'aurai bon dix ans que
c'est quoi votre billet ce n'est pas la
france non non et oui on est algérien et
marocain et tunisien et cetera et est-ce
que vous parlez déjà la langue
maternelle de votre bille non est ce que
vous vous l'avez déjà visité nom et donc
ils sangles ils sont ici ils sont nés
ici mais ils se sentent pas d'ici et
donc je crois que je trouve que c'est un
sort de paradoxes et de douleur et de
malheurs commence quand ces jeunes vont
grandir dans cette atmosphère dans cette
république qui lui appartiennent pas et
je trouve que le blue dangereux car
l'atmosphère générale dans les epep
établissements scolaires transforme de
la parole de la république à la baronne
de la radicalisation c'est à dire parler
de la république aujourd'hui dans
certains bâtiments les intelligences
colère d'un certain certains quartiers
où certains coins en france est devenu
un discours inacceptable un discours
divers ça s'appelle une chambre en exil
c'est aux éditions flammarion c'est une
forme de roman d'apprentissage d'une
certaine manière c'est aussi un
avertissement sur l'état de notre
démocratie
sur ce pays rongé par endroits par
l'islamisme radical et un livre
important à l'heure des bombardements
sur l'ukraine aussi j montre qu'après la
syrie l'histoire se répète vous rester
avec moi omar youssef souleymane on va
parler à présent encore et toujours de
la présidentielle c'est le scam avec nos
chroniqueurs pour passer au crible cet
entre deux tours avant avant le deuxième
tour tout de suite
[Musique]
mais avant mais dont il y a les deux
phrases de fatalité au grand
remplacement et de la môle vous propose
le rose delmore d'agir pour le climat
l'assimilation
la république c'est moi la prendre
orange ma chronique
travail aux travailleurs le système aux
exclus il ya un vrai problème de pouvoir
d'achat rendre à la france sa grandeur
et sa sert pas de mystère c'est de vol
trois chroniqueurs ce soir géraldine
muhlmann bonsoir politologue jean rémi
baudot france tv info chroniqueurs vous
connaissez visage familier de cette
émission et stéphane blakowski l'oeil de
blacko pour commencer à tirer par qui et
par quoi aujourd'hui d'avoir l'oeil rivé
sur les sondages on garde cette
variation il a gagné 0,5 à la perdu 0,5
me suis dit prenant du recul mais
vraiment du recul kw à 8 mois de recul
on regarde l'évolution de l'écart entre
macron et le pen depuis la rentrée de
septembre houllier juste qu'on fait
briller sa vaste espace 55 45 et puis
après bon la guerre en ukraine a profité
à macron son absence de campagne a
profité à le pen et là sur les derniers
jours on revient ce qui semble être le
rapport à peu près en ce moment en
france 55 45 entre maquereau et le pen
certains disent 56 44 bon le débat de
demain peuvent peut-être changer les
choses bouger les lignes mais comme vous
l'avez ni de débat c'est demain donc on
ne sait pas encore ce qu'il va se passer
a revanche des jours précédents on a
bien vu que chacun cherchait à
rassembler des électeurs de l'autre
quand françois mitterrand un disait au
premier tour on rassemble son camp au
deuxième tour on l'élargît donc c'est ce
que chacun a cherché à faire donc
mélenchon a parlé d'écologie pendant
tout son programme ça a bien marché
devinez de quoi macron a parlé à
marseille ça commence par ekos a fini
par j et coll la trop forte
bon évidemment c'est pas très sain ce
que j'ai fait mais la grave de macron
s'était pas non plus en finesse oui la
drague de fin de campagne c'est un peu
comme la dengue de fin de soirée en
boîte on s'adresse à des gens qui au
départ n'est pas prévue avant le draguer
on sait pas quoi leur dire de bas on
répète des trucs on imagine que ça leur
fait plaisir et bien écoutez macro
chacun prendra sa part dans ce combat du
siècle
chacun devra prendre sa part dans cet
avenir en commun que nous avons à
construire alors je vais peut-être pas
la réf mais le gros clin d'oeil c'était
venir en commun parce que ça c'est le
titre du programme de mélenchon alors
bon si les 28 ont pas compris vraiment
que iliad et la drague bon c'est
toujours un peu lourd encore une fois
mais il a été plus loin et là il a
repris le terme de planification
il a fait des promesses comme on en fait
mais qu'en fin de soirée ou en fin de
campagne électorale on écoute et donc le
ministre de la planification énergétique
aura pour mission de faire de la france
la première grande nation à sortir du
gaz du pétrole et du charbon
[Applaudissements]
mais voilà plus de gaz pétrole charbon
mais voilà pourquoi on s'ennuie et au
rassemblement national alors comment on
fait pour séduire les écologistes alors
on se dit que c'est moins facile à
priori et pourtant ils viennent des
propositions communes entre jadot et le
pen par exemple l'interdiction d'abattre
des animaux sans les étourdir pour les
abattages rituels donc ça obligerait les
juifs et les musulmans qui mange casher
et halal allait importer de la viande
donc ils ont pris positions nettes
reçues au nom de la défense amina animal
en fait on arrive alors la corrida c'est
pareil vous allez tourner au taureau
avant quand vous allez faire des
promesses de fin de campagne jamais
pourquoi vous n'interdisez pas tout
simplement la corrida puisque vous dites
au nom de mars bien est ce parce que là
encore vous savez que la tradition non
oui là encore je suis oui
on voit pas mais elle veut pas elle veut
pas
alors au rassemblement national aussi on
fait on fait marche arrière sur les
éoliennes bas ils s'étaient pas très
clair hier louis aliot était sur france
inter et divers mais on n'a pas du tout
prévu de démanteler toute éolienne
qu'est ce que vous racontez sauf que
l'easa mal ça là mais elle elle avait
entendu
le bannir le contraire donc ce n'est pas
très clair cette histoire on écoute
démanteler est un grand mot ne pas
renouveler je dirais à non elles
voulaient démanteler nom ne pas les
renouveler c'est à dire ne plus donner
des aides pour en installer et attendre
la fin de vie de celles qui y sommes
avant de passer à autre chose mais c'est
pas ce qui est prévu ce qui est saisie
c'est vous voulez l'aider mais non ce
n'est pas vrai non c'est pas vrai alors
que la marine le pen bon tu as chanté
sport solingen c'est une vingtaine
d'années donc ça veut dire que si on le
démonte pas bon rester longtemps dans le
paysage est bon je sais par une sangle
qu'en octobre il sent qu'elle voulait
vraiment des démons t on écoute
j'arrête toute nouvelle construction de
parcs éoliens et je lance un grand
chantier pour les démonter même voyez
voilà donc au moins c'est clair vous
voyez le montrent et oulémas oui moi je
ne suis pas emmanuel macron moi j'ai des
positions claires j'ai des convictions
je n'en change pas bon voilà
à trèves évident voilà c'était
soi-disant la dernière ligne droite qui
on voit bien que tout le monde l'igs à
guimps eu l'idée de séduire un derniers
indécis avant voilà ambiance de fin de
campagne quoi omar youssef soliman elle
vous amuse aussi cette campagne a gravi
oui bah oui
oui allégé comprend pas toujours vous
faites très vrai un peu compliqué comme
système pour moi mais j'estime qu'au
personnellement et je vais voter macron
au deuxième tour juste pour mettre
barrières aux extrémistes parce que j'ai
aucune envie qu'on marine le pen passe
soit notre prochain président tout
simplement alors vous allez adorer la
chronique de changer de voie d'eau qui
va nous expliquer que un pays il fait
pour le bipartisme est en fait un pays
politique qui se joue à trois blocs
trois parties qui perturbe complètement
de vie politique c'est un profond
changement qu'on est en train de vivre
la tripolarisation de vie politique pour
schématiser un bloc de gauche radicale
et écologiste un bloc central et libéral
et un bloc de droite et identitaire
alors on va pas parler ce soir de la
composition parce que par exemple je
doute que la france insoumise puisse
réellement revendiquer comme elle le
fait l'unique leadership du bloc de
gauche mais je m'interroge est
effectivement sur les conséquences de la
fin du bipartisme c'est quand même là
dessus cas et et ont été fondés la vème
république et nos institutions la droite
la gauche la promesse de d'alternance
comme le disait brice teinturier ce
matin sur france 5 r on veut faire
rentrer 3 france en deux et forcément ça
coince c'est ce qui explique aussi
l'incertitude de 6 oui réduire à 2 c'est
évidemment la logique de la démocratie
mais ça crée beaucoup de frustration
chez le troisième ça s'expriment plus
fortement on l'a vu chez les jeunes
aussi parce que ce sont plutôt eux qui
ont voté pour ce bloc de gauche mais
plus largement on sait qu'on comprend
qu'un tiers des électeurs ne se retrouve
pas du tout dans les propositions des
finalistes la conséquence elle est quand
même dangereux c'est un risque de
désengagement et une forte abstention
alors qu'est-ce qu'il faudrait remettre
tout à plat il fonde en institution il
faut revoir très vite nos institutions
pour leur marine le pen elle propose par
exemple de redonner la parole au peuple
via l'utilisation du référendum emmanuel
macron lui promet de gouverner autrement
et promet un un grand débat permanent
mais ils l'imaginent dans le même temps
un nouveau parti unique bon bref en
réalité il serait surtout temps de
s'interroger sur notre représentation
sur la représentativité du parlement et
sur la recherche de compromis il faut
d'urgence repenser le système
concrètement plutôt que de vouloir
lancer des réformes très rapidement au
début du quinquennat est ce qu'il
faudrait pas prendre le temps
d'organiser de vraies discussions de
remettre à plat notre système
démocratique
quand on voit la tension qu'il ya dans
le pays je me demande ce qu'il faut
comme alerte pourrait bien qu'on fasse
réellement cet effort pour vous il ya
vraiment urgence oui parce qu'on ne sait
pas collectivement écouter et prendre en
compte les copains aux hôtes de cette
nouvelle donne politique parce que
l'absence de proportionnelle écrase des
oppositions parce que ni notre exécutif
ni notre législatif non la culture du
compromis on voit les l'écu âgées dans
cette humble maison les que les
questions au gouvernement ça ressemble
quand même plus un cirque qu'à une
séance de concertation parce qu'il faut
permettre comme en rose la position de
porter une voix ne serait ce que pour
les mettre au défi de proposer des
solutions crédibles dont elle serait
éventuellement comptable et puis parce
que pourquoi d'urgence parce qu'il ya
quand même toute une partie de la
population qui se demande pourquoi il
faut aller voter alors évidemment ça ça
touche beaucoup la jeunesse pourtant
très très politisé très engagé très
mobilisés il faut quand même rapidement
cas si l'idée que voter ne sert plus à
rien et que le compromis n'est pas utile
à la démocratie
sinon qu'on abandonne petit à petit le
débat à la seule radicalité on
entretient le clash on assène les idées
en gros c'est les réseaux sociaux c'est
un travail de fond devant nous il est
compliqué d'éducation à la citoyenneté
les politiques ont un rôle les médias
aussi ont leur responsabilité
mais notre démocratie nappe roland pu
luxe tendre et je souscris complètement
à cette merveilleuse chronique il est
plus que temps de changer notre système
politique vous allez pas me contredire
je pense géraldine alors avec vous ce
soir on va se calmer une phrase de jean
castex qui a dit ce matin qu'en cas de
réélection d'emmanuel nacre où il
présentera sa démission dans les jours
suivants oui on va l'écouter c'était sur
france inter avec léa salamé et nicolas
demorand
après s'être élections dans les jours
qui suivent comme le veut je le disais
la traduction je présenterai ma
démission et celle du gouvernement au
président de la république donc jusqu'à
la semaine prochaine théoriquement selon
les textes vous avez le droit de rester
jusqu'aux législatives
encore une fois tout départ du sort des
urnes dimanche
je trouve qu'il ya beaucoup de choses à
entendre dans sa phrase qu'il
démissionnerait et la question des de
léa salamé la manière dont il répond en
fait elle a raison léa salamé il pour il
pourrait tout à fait rester l'article 8
de la constitution dit que le président
de la république nomme le premier
ministre mais il n'a pas le pouvoir de
le révoquer il ne met fin à ses
fonctions que sur présentation par
celui-ci de la démission du gouvernement
et la démission forcée du gouvernement
ne pourrait arriver que par une motion
de censure votée par l'assemblée
nationale c'est l'article 50 enfin on
imagine mal que jean castex reste après
l'élection du nouveau président en effet
myriam quand on est du même camp
politique en général et bien la demande
du président de la république le premier
ministre démissionne donc ce que suggère
en fait là castex et qu'il est probable
que macron s'il est réélu lui demande de
partir et qu'il acceptera il y aurait
donc une nouvelle équipe gouvernementale
avant les législatives
pourquoi pas sûrement pour marquer un
nouveau départ emmanuel macron a annoncé
on l'a vu tout à l'heure avec blaco à un
premier ministre qui sera en même temps
chargé de la planification écologique
il ya des pronostics la gestion
énergétique bon allez peut-être
elisabeth bornes peut-être un autre
ministre peut-être d'ailleurs aussi un
élu parce qu'ils n'arrêtent pas de
parler là c'est vous qui nous l'avait
dit d'un grand d'un grand parti en
mouvement d'unité d'action et puis il
aime bien les surprises macron alors on
peut rêver ce matin cécile duflot 10
elle et pourquoi pas mélenchon alors
j'ai quand même l'impression que leur
indiquait ce soir étonne il revendique
il a demandé sur bfm ce soir qu'on
l'élise premier ministre par donner un
ravin parle de mélenchon donc c'est ce
qu'a dit cécile duflot ce matin a fait
toute une chronique sur france inter oc
et puis pourquoi pas nicolas hulot part
au large et fait une très mauvaise
blague oui alors on va se mettre dans
une situation de victoire de marine le
pen c'est une possibilité est ce que la
nouvelle présidente est ce que là elle
pourrait être dans une situation jean
castex refuserait pas retirer ces
documents pour ça que je voulais faire
cette chronique ce scan parce que
évidemment que se passe-t-il si marine
le pen est au pouvoir ar je rappelle
qu'en 2010 est le premier ministre
bernard cazeneuve avait dit à quelques
journalistes un peu en off mais ses
sorties que dans l'hypothèse marine le
pen il resterait en place ensuite il n'a
pas totalement confirmé en jean castex
pourrait donc avoir des raisons de ne
pas démissionner alors qu'est ce que ça
voudrait dire pour faire quoi
précisément ce serait ballot empêcher
bien sûr la nouvelle présidente d'avoir
les mains libres avant les prochaines
élections législatives
alors là on est dans la politique
fiction mais enfin il n'est pas absurde
d'imaginer par exemple qu'une marine le
pen présidente ait envie d'utiliser
l'article 11 assez vite de la
constitution pour mettre en oeuvre les
référendum qu'elle a promis par exemple
sur la priorité à donner aux nationaux
sur les étrangers pour certaines aides
sociales pour les emplois or avec
l'article 11 elle n'aurait pas besoin
nécessairement d'une proposition c'est à
dire en accord des assemblées mais par
contre elles auraient besoin à ce moment
là d'une proposition d'un accord du
gouvernement donc d'un être humain
ministre du jean castex qui qui serait
donc en n'étant pas
démissionnaire finalement le barrage
alors il ya toute façon le conseil
constitutionnel qui pourrait barrer la
route au projet de l'ada ouvriers non
parce que le conseil constitutionnel
donnerait certainement sur ce sujet un
avis négatif mais bon ce serait qu'un
avis et dans ce pays il n'y a pas de
juge constitutionnel qui peut comme ça
allait à l'elysée est arrêté le
président et une fois adopté je précise
une loi référendaire ne peut plus être
annulée par le conseil constitutionnel
donc je redis qu'il ne s'agit que
nombreuses thèses et enfin le barrage le
plus évident à l' usage de l'article 11
par le ou la président de la publie pas
ses seins les assemblées et dans ce cas
l'opposition en ce moment en l'état
actuel est probable et 2 le premier
ministre donc un cas ce texte non
démissionnaires en tout cas jusqu'aux
législatives et d'ailleurs par ailleurs
marine le pen pourrait avoir envie
d'avancer cela est sans doute la scène
nationale gagnerait peut-être de trois
semaines c'est très intéressant il ya
que sur s&p qu'on apprend à lire la
constitution dans les moindres détails
merci infiniment jean rémi baudot
stéphane blakowski géraldine muhlmann
omar youssef souleymane je rappelle le
titre de votre roman que vous - roman
proche de voir une chambre en exil c'est
chez flammarion fin de cette émission
merci de l'avoir suivi tout de suite
votre soirée documentaire ce soir un
film sur la surveillance numérique
généralisée en chine ma femme a du
crédit de sébastien bay les éternels
soirée à demain
[Musique]